watson is standing down as an MP let's
bring in John Craig this break in the
last couple of minutes as Boris Johnson
was on stage this is a bombshell this is
but huge surprise this will rock the
Labour Party no doubt all those left
wingers who have been very critical of
mr. Watson will be delighted let me tell
you what he said he has said after 35
years in full-time politics I've decided
to step down and we'll be campaigning to
overcome the Tory fueled public health
crisis I was committed to labour as ever
I will spend this election fighting for
brilliant labour candidates and a better
future for our country now in his letter
to mr. Corbyn
he says I've taken the very difficult
decision to stand down as MP and labour
deputy leader serving a Labour Party's
been a privilege of a lifetime talks
about his history he talks about 18
years representing the people of his
constituency then talk about the black
country but now is the right time for me
to stand down about and about a
different kind and start a different
kind of life the decision is personal
not political well he has has his
clashes with the Labour leadership and
mr corbyn's allies he says that the last
few years have been among the most
transformational of my personal life
second only becoming to a proud father
two beautiful children I have become
healthy for the first time when of
course mr. Watson's belongs a huge diet
lost seven stone I intend to continue
with this work in the years to come he
says I want to thank you for the decency
and courtesy you've shown me even in
difficult times well mr. Corbyn may have
done but many mr corbyn's allies haven't
he tooks our shared interest he talks
about he says I will continue how many
shared interests are less well known in
our political differences I'll continue
to devote myself to the things we often
talk about gambling reform music and
arts at stopping press intrusion obesity
public health course horticulture and
cycling our men then he says in the
years to come I'll be focusing even more
on those policy interests I will devote
myself to
ting about the public health challenge
facing our country taking on the sugar
companies campaigning for policy change
setting up a remission for all movement
the type 2 diabetics I have a book on
downsize coming out in the new year you
knew that I announced further plans in
the coming months I might be standing
down as an MP but I won't be leaving
politics altogether this election is a
turning point for our country I know
that labor goes into it united in our
determination to remove the Conservative
government that has done so much damage
to the communities labor was founded to
respect he says I will be taking an
active part in this election campaign I
will continue as deputy leader until the
12th of December
that's the election day and we'll do
everything I can to return a team of
Labour MPs who will transform our
country I believe in my whole heart last
sentence what I believe when I joined on
that on the 5th my 15th birthday the
Labour Party is the most powerful
vehicle for social change this country
has ever produced I will never stop
fighting for it